filming for future Barack Obama recently
pledged 8 billion dollars in federal
support for a national network of
high-speed rail trains that can carry
passengers at speeds in excess of 150
miles per hour but the super train
fantasy is a mistake for at least three
reasons we're providing eight billion
dollars in seed money that eight billion
dollars won't come close to funding the
national plan which CNN reports could
cost over five hundred billion dollars
rail projects like most
government-funded extravaganzas have a
funny way of ballooning in cost in less
than two years time for instance cost
estimates for California's plan bullet
trains between Los Angeles and the Bay
Area have increased by a third up to
about forty three billion dollars some
estimates say that by the time the
Golden State project is completed in
2020 it'll cost more than a hundred
billion dollars we're gonna be taking
cars off a congested highways reducing
carbon emissions because high-speed rail
has decided to carry people from city to
city it won't have any effect on urban
traffic congestion which mostly takes
place within a given metro area think
about it
flying from Boston to New York doesn't
reduce inbound traffic at the Lincoln
Tunnel neither will taking a high-speed
train and don't confuse high-speed rail
with magic carpets that run on
newfangled clean energy all but two of
the proposed lines run on diesel Amtrak
is a notorious money pit costing
taxpayers at least thirty five billion
dollars in handouts its per passenger
subsidies averaged about $50 per ticket
a hundred and forty million people
schlep to work each Monday through
Friday
Amtrak carries just 78,000 people per
day and the overseas experience isn't
all that great either only two bullets
one in France and one in Japan have
recovered their capital costs and all of
them require massive ongoing subsidies
from taxpayers if we're looking to
reduce traffic congestion and travel
delays it makes more sense to build more
roads and to increase the number of
airplane flights by modernizing the air
traffic control system bullet trains may
be fun to talk about but don't expect
them to carry you or the United States
into the future any time soon
I'm excited I'm gonna come back down
here and write for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie